this is all wrong I shouldn't be up here
I should be back in school on the other
side of the ocean yet you all come to us
young people for hope how dare you you
have stolen my dreams in my childhood
with your empty words yet I'm one of the
lucky ones people are suffering people
are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is money
and fairytales of eternal economic
growth how dare you for more than 30
years the science has been crystal clear
how dare you continue to look away and
come here saying that you're doing
enough when the politics and solutions
needed are still nowhere in sight you
say you hear us and that you understand
the urgency but no matter how sad and
angry I am I do not want to believe that
because if you really understood the
situation and still kept on failing to
act then you would be evil and that I
refuse to believe
[Applause]
the popular idea of cutting our
emissions in half in 10 years only gives
us a 50% chance of staying below 1.5
degrees and the risk of setting of
irreversible chain reactions beyond
human control 50% may be acceptable to
you
but those numbers do not include tipping
points most feedback loops additional
warming hidden by toxic air pollution or
the aspects of equity and climate
justice they also rely on my generation
sucking hundreds of billions of tons of
your co2 out of the air with
technologies that barely exist so a 50%
risk is simply not acceptable to us we
who have to live with the consequences
[Applause]
how dare you pretend that this can be
sold with just business as usual and
some technical solutions with today's
emissions levels that remaining co2
budgets will be entirely gone within
less than eight and a half years there
will not be any solutions or plans
presented in line with these figures
here today because these numbers are too
uncomfortable and you are still not
mature enough to tell it like it is you
are failing us but the young people are
starting to understand your betrayal the
eyes of all future generations are upon
you and if you choose to fail us I say
we will never forgive you
[Applause]
we will not let you get away with this
right here right now is where we draw
the line the world is waking up and
change is coming whether you like it or
not thank you
[Applause]